Trascrizione: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
Nel caffe che avete bevuto prima,
o che berrete domattina,
magari ripensando a questo stesso talk,
accadranno dei fenomeni
misteriosi, complessi,
quanto quelli che crediamo accadano
nello spazio più remoto tra le galassie.
E il cervello che userete
per pensare a tutto questo,
sappiate che in base alla fisica moderna
è uno degli oggetti
più complessi dell’universo,
complesso almeno tanto quanto
la distribuzione di tutte le galassie
che potremo mai osservare nell’universo.
Queste cose non sono
delle sparate di fantascienza
o peggio, di pseudoscienza.
Sono dei punti lungo il percorso
che fisica e astrofisica stanno compiendo
nella direzione di includere concetti,
idee della teoria della complessità,
che è un campo di ricerca molto vasto,
molto interdisciplinare,
e che è stato premiato,
come forse ricorderete,
circa un mese fa,
con il premio Nobel per la Fisica
all’italiano Giorgio Parisi.
Tra le tante cose che spero vi affascinino
che vi racconterò oggi
vorrei che ve ne restasse
almeno una impressa.
Noi crediamo in fisica
che quando due eventi
sono veramente complessi,
anche se avvengono su scale di tempo
e di spazio incredibilmente diverse,
e sto per mostrarvi forse i due estremi
possibili nel nostro universo,
questi fenomeni possono essere
simili tra di loro,
perché indipendentemente
dalle interazioni,
dalle forze fondamentali che li regolano,
possono autocreare
un livello di organizzazione
che risponde a dinamiche
e logiche superiori,
che li fanno appunto assomigliare.
Prima di parlare di tutto questo,
vi racconto un po’ di me.
Quando ero più giovane,
diciamo proprio più piccolo,
avrei voluto essere questo, un archeologo.
Questa cosa che vedete
è un reperto archeologico.
Anch’esso è una ricerca
sugli antichi Fenici,
credo di seconda o terza elementare.
Ve la mostro perché ritornerà più avanti.
Avrei voluto studiare il passato
della civiltà umana,
per capirne meglio il presente.
Beh, gli astronomi non fanno
una cosa molto diversa,
cercano di sondare
il passato remoto dell’universo,
andando veramente miliardi
e miliardi di anni in là nel tempo,
sia con la teoria,
sia con le osservazioni, dove riescono,
con l’obiettivo di spiegare
quello che invece i telescopi ci mostrano
nell’universo attorno a noi.
Vi mostro un caso,
un caso pratico.
Almeno per noi astrofisici
questo è un caso pratico.
Questo è un ammasso di galassie,
è una grande megalopoli cosmica.
Tutti i puntini che vedete qui,
i puntini luminosi, non sono stelle,
sono singole galassie,
sono singole città stellari,
molto simili alla nostra Via Lattea
o magari diversi dalla Via Lattea,
ma ciascuno di questi puntini luminosi
contiene circa 100 miliardi di stelle.
In questo senso, questa
è una grande provincia cosmica,
fatta di tante città stellari,
che negli ultimi miliardi di anni
sono tenute assieme dalla forza di gravità
e orbitano in modo caotico
intorno al centro di massa
di questo sistema,
che è esteso milioni di anni luce.
Una struttura che vedete
in basso invece in rosso
è chiamata relitto radio.
La possiamo osservare invece
se accediamo alla parte radio
dello spettro elettromagnetico.
Questa struttura è gigante.
È lunga circa sei milioni
di anni luce da parte a parte.
Potrebbero starci comodamente
almeno 50 galassie come la nostra,
messe una in fila all’altra.
È un ambiente di densità bassissima.
Qui la densità è un miliardo di miliardi
di miliardi di volte più bassa
dell’aria che respiriamo.
Ciononostante, qui crediamo sia avvenuto
uno dei più grandi cataclismi
della storia dell’universo.
Questa che è una perturbazione
vera e propria si sta spostando,
noi crediamo,
verso il basso dell’immagine,
alla velocità di circa
6.000 chilometri al secondo.
Nonostante la densità qui sia bassissima,
l’energia complessivamente associata
a questa perturbazione,
che è veramente
un’onda di tsunami cosmica,
ci fa dire che qui deve essere avvenuto,
circa 5 miliardi di anni fa,
uno degli eventi più cataclismatici,
più energetici
dell’intera vita dell’universo.
Conosciamo tanti sistemi come questo,
questo è uno dei più spettacolari.
Come facciamo a capire
che cosa è avvenuto qui?
Gli astrofisici fanno qualcosa di simile
a quello che fanno i meteorologi.
Cerchiamo di fare
delle previsioni del tempo,
però noi prevediamo il passato.
Abbiamo osservazioni che ci raccontano
più o meno il presente astrofisico.
Cerchiamo di chiederci
cosa è successo nel passato,
e quali leggi fisiche hanno prodotto
quello che osserviamo adesso.
Come fanno i meteorologi,
inseriamo in un calcolatore
le forze fondamentali
che crediamo di conoscere,
sono quattro in natura,
e le componenti di materia principale,
e evolviamo ciò
che queste equazioni fanno.
Occorrono tanti computer,
usiamo il calcolo parallelo,
migliaia e migliaia di computer
che lavorano in simultanea,
facciamo una storia presunta
del passato dell’Universo,
e la confrontiamo con le osservazioni.
Se il modello si accorda bene,
stiamo imparando qualcosa.
Però questo è difficile,
perché siamo di fronte
a uno dei fenomeni più complessi,
ma anche comuni dell’universo:
la turbolenza dei fluidi.
Potete fare l’esperimento,
per esempio domattina:
se provate a mescolare tante volte
le stesse poche gocce di caffè,
in una tazza di latte,
per vedere meglio il contrasto,
vedrete che se rifate
lo stesso esperimento tante volte
non riuscirete mai a prevedere esattamente
che strutture si formeranno.
Potrete dire che, dopo qualche secondo,
latte e caffè si saranno miscelati,
ma le strutture che si formeranno
esattamente da un caso all’altro
saranno sempre diverse.
Questo perché la turbolenza
è un regime della fisica
nella quale i fluidi sono soggetti
a una cosiddetta non linearità:
delle minuscole differenze
nelle condizioni iniziali,
per esempio l’angolo con cui mettete
il cucchiaio nella tazza di caffè e latte
cambia l’evoluzione e la cambia
in modo completamente divergente,
completamente diverso
da una storia all’altra,
siamo in un regime caotico.
Anche se ce l’abbiamo
con i meteorologi
perché sbagliano una previsione
da qui a due giorni,
volevamo andare al mare invece piove,
sappiate che, nemmeno con tutta la potenza
di calcolo disponibile al mondo,
voi sapreste prevedere che cosa succederà
nella vostra tazzina di caffè
domani esattamente.
Applicando questo problema
all’astrofisica,
dobbiamo produrre simulazioni al computer
estremamente grandi, estremamente lunghe,
e farne tante, e vedere quella
che meglio si accorda con i dati.
Quella che vi mostro è quella
che il mio gruppo ha prodotto
che meglio si accorda
con la formazione di quel relitto radio
che vi mostravo all’inizio.
State per vedere l’evoluzione
in pochi secondi
di quello che crediamo sia successo
in cinque miliardi di anni.
E quello che state per vedere è
come queste masse di gas rarefattissimo
in giallo e arancione,
si mescolano tra di loro,
trascinate dalla forza
di gravità delle galassie,
che stanno evolvendo in questo sistema.
Le tracce azzurre sono
dove noi possiamo prevedere
che si formino questi lampi radio,
e verso la fine uno di questi
lampi radio simulati
si sovrappone molto bene
al vero relitto radio osservato.
Questa è una vera immagine.
Possiamo quindi dire che abbiamo
un modello simulato
che tiene conto delle interazioni
fondamentali della natura
che qui ci interessano,
che sono soprattutto la gravità
e la fluidodinamica, il modo in cui
i fluidi si mescolano tra di loro,
e tutto questo ci dà un modello fedele
di un fenomeno, per esempio astrofisico,
che vogliamo studiare.
La possibilità di avere simulazioni
accurate di un qualche fenomeno fisico
è anche fondamentale
per rispondere a un’altra domanda,
apparentemente più evanescente,
ma per me molto affascinante,
che è: cos’è la complessità?
Come faccio a dire
che qualcosa è complesso?
Come faccio a quantificarlo?
Come faccio a paragonare tra di loro
fenomeni che penso essere complessi
ma che sono di tipo completamente diverso?
Qui sfruttiamo un’idea che è partita
in realtà 50-60 anni fa,
per esempio da un fisico sovietico
geniale, Andrej Kolmogorov,
che non casualmente ha fatto anche
molti studi sulla turbolenza.
Noi possiamo dire
che la lunghezza del programma,
dell’algoritmo che usiamo
per fare una simulazione,
e la quantità di dati
che occorre al programma
per iniziare a funzionare
e produrre la simulazione
sono una misura molto accurata,
o la migliore misura possibile,
della complessità del fenomeno stesso.
Il che non è molto diverso dal dire
che un piatto di alta cucina
è più complesso tipicamente,
se richiede una ricetta molto lunga
e magari molti ingredienti.
E noi sappiamo come misurare
la quantità di informazione.
In informatica tramite il numero di bit,
tramite le unità di codice binario 0 o 1,
che ci occorrono per codificare
una certa sequenza di dati.
Oppure possiamo usare il multiplo del bit,
che sono i byte, 8 bit fanno un byte.
Questo è importante perché,
ritornando un attimo all’archeologia,
che come vedete
non ho mai abbandonato del tutto,
è una specie di stele di Rosetta.
La stele di Rosetta è questo documento,
questa lastra di granito,
che circa 220 anni fa
è stata usata per la prima volta
per decifrare il linguaggio geroglifico,
perché in questa lastra è riportato
lo stesso editto del faraone
in geroglifico, che era ignoto all’epoca,
in una variante dell’egizio antico,
anch’essa ignota,
e nel greco antico
che invece era conosciuto.
Avendo in uno stesso
documento le trascrizioni
delle stesse informazioni
in diversi linguaggi
abbiamo potuto conoscere
per la prima volta
il significato del linguaggio geroglifico.
Usando lo stesso approccio,
da qualche anno,
sto sia simulando l’universo,
come si fa in tanti centri di ricerca,
in questo caso simulando l’intera rete,
o una grande porzione
della rete cosmica delle galassie,
e usando gli stessi dati astrofisici
per estrarre dal flusso di dati
prodotto dalla simulazione
anche la quantità di bit
che descrivono l’evoluzione
di tante parti diverse dell’universo.
Qui vedete la formazione
di due ammassi di galassie in centro,
queste strutture più rosse.
Possiamo usare questo dato, per esempio,
per farne un normale studio astrofisico.
Questo che vedete è un ingrandimento
che mostra l’energia associata
a queste perturbazioni del gas
che seguono la formazione
di un ammasso di galassie.
Questa è invece la mappa della complessità
che possiamo estrarre dal flusso
di dati della simulazione
con metodi un po’ avanzati.
È una mappa veramente
colorata in unità di bit.
Dove i colori sono più accesi,
li è avvenuta l’evoluzione più complessa.
Dove abbiamo pochi colori,
l’evoluzione è stata molto semplice,
ad esempio nei vuoti cosmici.
Questo ci permette
di quantificare la complessità
con un numero che posso confrontare.
Una cosa che posso fare
è estrapolare queste simulazioni,
che non arrivano mai a coprire
la totalità dell’universo osservabile,
che stimiamo abbia un raggio
di 46 miliardi di anni luce.
Noi non possiamo mai coprire
tutto l’universo osservabile
con un’unica simulazione,
possiamo però estrapolare
dati dei campioni molto grandi simulati,
e una stima verosimile che per descrivere
l’evoluzione dell’intera rete cosmica
ci occorrono 32 milioni
di miliardi di bit,
ovvero circa quattro petabyte e mezzo.
Quant’è questo numero, è tanto, è poco,
sembra gigantesco, in effetti lo è,
però è nell’ordine dei dati
che produce ogni giorno
una grande rete sociale complessa
come quella di Facebook.
Però se volessimo fermarci a qualcosa
di ancora più affascinante
e che portiamo qui tutti quanti,
anche in questo momento,
la rete neuronale, la rete
dei neuroni del nostro cervello
è stato stimato che possa
codificare, possa contenere,
una quantità di memoria molto simile,
dello stesso ordine di grandezza.
Allora qualche anno fa mi sono rivolto
a un neurochirurgo di fama internazionale,
che attualmente lavora presso
l’Ospedale dell’Università di Verona,
per proporgli un confronto quantitativo
tra campioni simulati del web
della rete cosmica di galassie
e campioni reali del cervello umano.
Abbiamo in effetti prodotto questo lavoro
che è uscito alla fine dell'anno scorso
in una rivista scientifica.
Questo lavoro è stato ripreso
quasi istantaneamente
dai media di mezzo mondo,
tradotto in tutte le lingue,
a riprova del grande fascino
che questo tema esercita su di noi.
Non è stata la nostra
prima ricerca assieme,
la prima ve l’ho già mostrata.
Eravamo in effetti compagni
di banco alle elementari.
Diciamo che questa seconda ricerca
è stata letta e apprezzata
da un po’ più di persone.
Che cosa abbiamo trovato?
Allora, abbiamo analizzato
in modo quantitativo e oggettivo,
con gli stessi metodi,
presi soprattutto dall’astrofisica
e dalla scienza delle reti complesse,
dei campioni diversi,
sia della rete cosmica simulata
sia di campioni di vetrini
ottenuti al microscopio
della corteccia cerebrale
e del cervelletto,
due parti fondamentali del cervello umano.
Li abbiamo analizzati in modo simile
e abbiamo trovato una quantità
stupefacente di somiglianze.
Il numero di nodi,
ovvero galassie in un caso
o neuroni nell’altro,
sono molto simili:
100 miliardi stimiamo siano le galassie,
80 miliardi sono i neuroni, stimiamo.
Abbiamo analizzato
la topologia delle due reti
ovvero abbiamo schematizzato queste reti
come una sequenza di nodi e filamenti
che connettono la rete spazialmente.
Abbiamo trovato
dei parametri molto simili:
il numero di connessioni
e di filamenti per nodo nei due casi
è molto simile.
La tendenza che i nodi hanno
a raggrupparsi in macronodi,
formando degli hub,
come quelli degli aeroporti,
è molto simile.
Abbiamo usato una tecnica astrofisica
chiamata spettro di potenza,
che si usa molto anche per la cosmologia,
per studiare come la massa si distribuisca
oltre i vuoti e i pieni nei due sistemi
in modo molto simile.
E l’impronta che questo
spettro di potenza ha
è molto diversa se applichiamo
la stessa tecnica
ad altri sistemi naturali
apparentemente simili.
Abbiamo ricavato ancora
la complessità dei due sistemi
che sembra essere
dello stesso ordine di grandezza.
È molto affascinante,
perché si tratta di due sistemi
che sono separati tra di loro
da 27 ordini di grandezza
in scale spaziali.
Da una parte abbiamo
miliardi di anni luce
e d’altra parte abbiamo
dieci centimetri grosso modo.
Che cosa ci dice tutto questo?
Vi dico che cosa non ci dice.
Non ci dice che il cervello umano
contiene un universo,
non ci dice che l’universo
è un cervello pensante.
Nulla di tutto ciò.
Tutto questo ci ripete qualcosa
che vi accennavo all'inizio.
Siamo in presenza di due spettacolari
fenomeni emergenti.
Ovvero abbiamo due sistemi,
la cui evoluzione è prescritta
da interazioni semplici,
in un caso è la forza di gravità,
dall’altra parte abbiamo
scambi di forze elettrochimiche.
In entrambi i casi abbiamo tantissime
componenti che interagiscono tra di loro.
Da questo marasma di interazioni
emergono delle strutture,
che possiamo schematizzare
come reti complesse,
che tendono ad assomigliarsi.
Di fenomeni emergenti
ne conosciamo tantissimi in natura
ne scopriamo sempre di più,
noi stessi siamo un fenomeno emergente.
Una cosa affascinante
è che la possiamo applicare,
per esempio per visualizzare
la creazione di branchi di animali
o di stormi di uccelli,
la crescita dei batteri,
il propagarsi delle epidemie
o il loro contrasto tramite i vaccini,
tema che è estremamente d’attualità,
la creazione di reti sociali
con poli dominanti, eccetera.
Tutti questi non sono esempi
della stessa rete complessa in alcun modo,
ma sono tutti fenomeni emergenti,
fenomeni nei quali la moltitudine
delle interazioni semplici
di componenti microscopiche di un sistema
crea qualcosa che vediamo
solo quando facciamo un passo indietro,
ci allontaniamo e cominciamo a vedere
un’organizzazione su scala più grande.
Per concludere, cosa possiamo dire?
Da un lato, i fenomeni emergenti
credo che siano una frontiera
che la fisica sta già affrontando
e affronterà.
Per esempio in cosmologia,
dobbiamo capire come ha fatto l’universo,
partendo dalla situazione più omogenea
e isotropa che potete immaginare,
13 miliardi di anni fa,
a creare questa incredibile gerarchia
di struttura della scala subnucleare,
atomica, molecolare,
gli organismi, i pianeti,
le stelle, le galassie,
la rete dell’universo e così via.
Dall’altra parte, lo dico da astrofisico,
una cosa che a me affascina assolutamente,
che trovo inspiegabile,
è come l’interazione continua
di questa moltitudine
di 80 miliardi di cellule,
sostanzialmente ignare l’una dell’altra,
riesca continuamente a creare
questa struttura persistente,
molto astratta ma molto reale,
perché la stiamo vivendo
in questo istante,
che è la nostra coscienza,
che siamo noi stessi,
e che è la curiosità che ci spinge
a fare domande così formidabili
sull’universo stesso.
Grazie.
(Applausi)